hey guys what's up this is andrew for
traincensus.com so in this video i would
like to talk about something a little
bit different from what i'm usually
talking about i remind you guys that i
live in hong kong and everybody is
talking about one thing today should we
buy alibaba so let's get into it
[Music]
and guys so in this video i want to talk
about the chinese tech companies so i'm
going to focus on alibaba because it's
listed on the us market uh i'm also
gonna have a look at tencent and at the
hsci which is the chinese index listed
in hong kong
so let's start with alibaba so basically
i have a lot of my friends that are
involved in this trade so let's do some
technical analysis here i'm also going
to talk a little bit about fundamentals
my point here is just to give my humble
opinion about where this might be going
and i think i have a quite good answer
to give so let's have a look at alibaba
chat so i'm checking baba u.s so it is
the one listed in the us
the one list in hong kong is dropping
today so we might see a lower level here
today as well and if i do the the
analysis since 2 or 15 i see that we
have completed a five waves move up
right we went to 320 since then we are
correcting heavily guys very heavily uh
the signal of the deeper correction
arrived here guys when we broke this
trend line that was broken retested once
re-tested twice you can see here we had
this double reaction as we often have
after this kind of breakout and we got
rejected at
230.
so
now the question we're having is is it a
good level to buy so right now we're
turning around 135
so to answer that question let's first
check where are the support levels on
this chart and one very natural obvious
support level is 130 why because it's
the bottom of the fourth wave you guys
know that whenever we break a five waves
uh pattern on the downside we usually
correct to the top of the third which
was our first support level here it hold
uh pretty well during august and then we
broke it so we go to the uh next support
level which is the bottom of the force
wave in terms of retracement how much
have you retraced
compared to the first move it's a lot
guys all right we are below the 61.8
percent so it's heavily retracing it's
oversold for sure here so i think that
buying the dip here is a nice
opportunity this is what we are going
trying to do in our live trading
portfolio on discord if you're not
following us follow us right now link in
description of this video you're gonna
find me and gabrielle who is an
experienced trader
located in panama that is working with
me and we are sharing with you guys a
lot of uh great content analysis and we
are showing you what we are doing so we
probably gonna get get into this one
once again my level is around 130. let's
quickly have a look at what is the price
earning ratio on baba because we can
compare alibaba to amazon right and let
me show you something guys okay
so i'm going to go quickly on bloomberg
all right so first i am here on amazon
and i check the estimated price earning
ratio which is around 61. all right and
we can compare alibaba to this because
they are doing roughly the same thing i
know that amazon is getting much of its
profits through
data storage that's true but alibaba is
actually doing the same guys all right
so this is the same kind of industry so
i'm not saying it should be uh the same
price earning ratio but it's just an
indication it's showing us so here we
have an estimated price of ratio of 15
guys
so it's extremely low it's four times
lower than amazon so address in time in
terms of price earning ratio we have a
three percent move up
that might come and this would only make
them equal
so i think that in terms of fundamentals
this is looking pretty good so why is it
dropping that heavily we need to to ask
ourselves and the reason behind i don't
think it's really related to alibaba i
mean of course there it is but not only
look at the hsc i guess the whole
chinese market is diving so i'm here
looking at the hci for the past 10 years
yes so you can see this market is very
rangy nothing much happened we are
getting we are coming close to the lows
of the coffee crisis guys the hsci
dropped to 8 300. we are retesting this
level it's totally crazy when you know
the s p 500 is still far above the level
it had before the coming crisis the hci
is close to the level uh at the of the
lows during this crisis so it's
extremely low once again the reason
behind that is by you guys know about
the ever ground issue they might default
uh people talk about uh about that again
today it's not the only reason
i think that people just fear the
chinese market because of the trade war
that started with trump we know also
that the chinese government they don't
think short-term you know they have a
long-term view zgp is going to be here
for maybe another 50 years guys so this
guy even if he's old he has time you
know so they're not injecting money
heavily in the economic system just as
the united states and the rest of the
world is doing so i think that they
might maybe win the long-term game but
in the short term of course it's not the
the best thing and the chinese
government they don't care about losing
some of their maybe big companies you
know they can they can handle that they
work in a way that uh this kind of
situations can be handled very well
which is not the case in the united
states where it would create you know a
domino effect with the other companies
in china they control what is happening
so this is i think the reason why
investors are scared uh and i think we
are close to the bottom here on the hsci
if we break 8500 we might quickly go to
the 7500 level and then we'll probably
come back so i think that buying the dip
makes sense on this uh very good
potential stocks like alibaba let's
quickly have a look at 10 cent guys look
so here i'm going to do the same type of
analysis and you can see that we have
this trend line that is holding since
2019 all right it's it's holding well i
see a fifth wave to come so once again
either you guys try to buy the the deep
here around 440
400 all right that's a good level or you
know the different way of trading is not
to buy the dip but to buy the breakouts
so you wait for a breakout you wait for
a re-test and you enter in this area so
around 500 and this would be more secure
you just enter whenever it starts to
move higher so this is
also something that you guys can do on
alibaba if you don't want to buy the dip
there is this trend line that is coming
just here guys at the blue trend line uh
that bam bam you know around 170 so i
think that if we trade above that
it would look good and it would probably
happen around 150 160 level so you have
two different types of trading i
personally gonna try to buy the deep
here because i believe in the company
fundamentals i'm going to use a wide
stop plus you know just to make sure
that i'm not getting kicked out uh at
the worst timing here and i'm i'm quite
positive for all of that i think we
still have some downside to come we we
are still bearish guys alright we are
not bullish yet but starting to buy the
deep is good and if things turn well
accumulating a bit higher uh is i think
a good thing as well so for all of those
who are long alibaba of 10 cent i think
the worst is almost behind us and that
better days are about to come that's it
for me i hope you guys enjoyed this
video and if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new and stay
close to show i see you guys